see that they can defeat me in every
sport
right they're probably brighter than i
am but they probably
survived longer in a survival situation
like
in alone or you know if they were on a
deserted island
right i'm weak right and they're better
than i am
all right i can't [ __ ] good i don't [ __ ]
good
and she knows it you know what i'll
admit i admit
to the i don't i [ __ ] sloppy
you don't do that with your sloppy can
be good thank you so much and that's why
i like you yeah
i think he just [ __ ] weird i [ __ ] weird
[ __ ]
weird could be good how do i [ __ ] um so
act maximum 11 and a half pumps maximum
wow but that half that half is extra
it's like super long because i only ca i
ca i only want to do 10.
right so i don't you know at 10 i'm like
i'm out
he's out and i go i gotta go that extra
one you know yeah
but the question is between you two who
has more body hair
it depends where what part of the body
come again what part of the body
yeah uh nipples
yeah oh that's a that's a great question
it might be my [ __ ] has more hair
i have to admit that because i have hair
in the inside as well oh
yeah yeah yeah so that's why in my hair
my hair distribution
as annie letterman calls it is very um
chemo patient
it's like it's a little patchy yeah it's
scarce in the front
i call it chernobyl yeah yeah yeah yeah
very chernobyly
yeah a little bit yeah um okay the hair
are you hairy no yeah i could use a
little
yeah i got no chest yeah i got the weird
nip hairs that get uh
you know get in the way shoot out yeah
you look like you [ __ ] good
now
[Laughter]
no i [ __ ] like my comedy it's stiff it's
quick
yeah it's not pretty not much of an
ending no closer
yeah i'm working on it but it's it's fun
though still huh
sex yeah yeah sure you know i still get
to
i'm still you know and as a 50 year old
man almost 50.
i still when i'm doing it in my mind i'm
always i'm like a teenager
yeah i think to myself i can't believe
i'm doing this i feel the same way
right and when they wake up but no it's
uh
but i feel the same way but the whole
time i'm thinking she's not into this
she doesn't like me
they say men worry about their
performance and women worry about their
appearance
yeah yes that's correct yeah you know
it's interesting
because you you know um i just have to
say this you know
um how do i say this sing it
i i think if i was gay yeah which i'm
not
jeremy um that i would find you to be
cute
oh thanks you're cute too
[Music]
i just i just want to let that sink in
yeah i mean
just let the silence speak for itself
there was a character on the
thundercats that you look like i love
thundercats yeah the little i think
you're nervous under
because it was intimate what we were
doing it was and you had to talk over it
i had to get out of it but
i i want you to look at me right now i
don't know don't get out of bed all
right
all right i'm gonna stretch slide back
in say
tell me that i'm cute again right look
at my eyes you don't talk for
30 seconds hold on i can't find your
eyes and you count them okay all right
very funny very much but no you're cute
all right thank yous
your feet aren't even hitting the you're
talking adorable you're talking all
right
see you're cute again and don't say
anything ready but lock eyes
[Laughter]
so here's what my point though is thank
you
my point is is that because i've seen
your stand up and stuff and there is
um you know you're cute you know you can
skate
you know you're from new orleans you
know you but you have this
low self-esteem sure yeah yeah and where
does that come from
i assume it's parental upbringing
something like that bedwetter
braces curly hair black neighborhood
a lot of it's a big gumbo of of bad news
yeah yeah yeah and i think that probably
did it you think so i guess
i don't know but it's so weird how
culturally braces there's such a thing
that like you get made fun
of over here yeah like where i come from
braces are so expensive
so it denotes it shows that someone has
status right they have money so
it's so if someone let's say the
orthodontist says oh it's been three
years take your braces off people wear
them until they're 60 years old